- To wrap the thing,
you just can't see any
of the present, right?
That's what wrapping is (laughs).
I'm here with always
anxious Mitchel Davis.
- I'm not anxious, I'm fine, I feel good.
- Like this.
- I feel good.
That's cause I got energy.
- You got ants in the pants.
We are creating a holiday tradition.
- Yes.
- Because this is the second time
that we have done this challenge here
on It's Grace, and it is the
human Christmas tree challenge.
Mitchel and I are going
to race to turn ourselves
into human Christmas trees.
We have all of our
accoutrements down here.
We have Christmas skirts, garland,
ornaments, candy canes, tape,
a gift to put under our tree
and oh antlers.
God, I feel like this is like
a beauty DIY video right now.
And we will race to decorate ourselves
like human Christmas trees
using all of the things
in front of us.
We can put them on in any order.
The only thing that has
to happen is that the gift
has to get wrapped last.
- I mean, typical.
- At the very end, one of us
will scream a holiday phrase
and that signifies that we are done.
- Yes.
- Okay.
Are you feeling okay?
- I'm feeling so good.
I'm feeling really good.
- Is this for this?
Oh, okay (laughs)
I thought you were doing like
I'm feeling really good.
- I feel so good.
How dare you (laughs).
- Oh these sweatshirts, um, yeah.
Last year Mark Douglas and I dressed up
in green sweatshirts and sweatpants
to signify the Christmas tree base.
We didn't have green sweatpants this year
so this year we're dead Christmas trees.
- Well we're in Las Angeles, you know,
there's no water here.
- Let's do the human
Christmas tree challenge
year number two.
- I'm ready.
- Okay.
- Jack?
- [Voiceover] You ready guys?
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] Ho, ho, go.
- I see what you did there.
How does this?
Oh my God, it's an actual...
- Okay, I feel beautiful.
Hi, oh.
- Always cinch the lace.
- Now me.
You don't even know.
Grab these guys.
See, that's what I'm talking about.
- I got four of each.
- Christmas trees.
Come back up here.
- No, no, no.
- Grace, grab that ball for me.
- Eat shit, holiday shit.
- You know what is holiday shit?
- What?
- My grandpa loves it.
It's so gross.
It's like a type of bread.
- Fruitcake.
- Fruitcake, yeah he loves the shit.
- I didn't know that about you and grandpa
have a relationship.
- Put some candy canes on the glasses.
How many candy canes?
- Four.
- How many candy canes?
- I have lost tape, so my tape plan
back fired on me.
- One
and two.
- You have to see them?
Oh they can be in my pockets.
- Three.
(laughs)
Four.
- Oh, I got something in my eyeball.
- Perfect.
Get away from me Grace.
Get away from me.
Oh shit, the present.
- Oh and the tape isn't open yet.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
- Have a merry Christmas.
- No.
Mitchel is (mumbles).
You put it on your glasses.
(laughs)
Goddamn my perfect vision.
- I got way more sweaty
than I anticipated.
- Yeah, this is a physical activity.
- Is that for me?
- This is for you.
- This one's for you.
- Awww.
No, you didn't put your thing
on the top of your gift.
There's a bow that goes
- I'm (mumbles) whatever.
(laughs)
- Well Mitchel thank you for participating
in year two of the human
Christmas tree challenge.
If you want to listen to
more of our holiday rants,
opinions, aggressions, desperations,
go to Sound Cloud or iTunes,
listen to the full episode not too deep
with Mitchel and yeah, I'm tired.
- Yeah, really it was...
Is this what trees go through every year?
- Oh my God.
- I feel so bad.
- Follow Mitchel on the internet.
Live lava live.
- Just stop, it's fine.
- I don't know.
- It's gotta be way heavier
just because he's always
got to help those old--
- Old bitties.
- Those old little teeny
little people (laughs).
Oh, come here and help me roll this sling.
I barely made it past two numbers.